the thing about pawns they can't move
backwards I'm not not the type of person
who likes to make commitments like that
well I'm playing the guy in first place
this is gonna be serious like actually
I'm gonna try and protect my win streak
playing I don't even know how to
pronounce this name I'll play what I
usually play it's be a lot more serious
using I am so he's clearly underrated
you saw me chess well half the time I'm
just staying with my usual tournament
repertoire
yeah this is one of the main like
classical variations Bishop b4 I'm
assuming he knows what to do f3 is not
the most like popular move f3 as far as
I know as a bit dubious the main line is
984 or even takes in Queen d4 this is
already okay kind of nice for black and
those simple ideas I might actually go
for d5 early also ideas of Bishop d6 can
be interesting b5 mix love sense here
well I just want to play Bishop e7 or
exceeds rook c8 s' maybe Bishop d6 maybe
d5 still at some point also ideas 95 to
c4 I'll niche the Queen and target c3 as
well and the structure I mean it looks
solid but it's hard to like fine plans
here is white
I mean f4 is one idea but it loses a
pawn in this Knight is restricted a 4 is
very interesting Wow a4 was not on my
radar but it's annoying move I might
have to take which I don't really want
to do consider taking on c3 some idea of
like 95 or Nighy 5 still I mean I'm
leaning towards taking like taking
Bishop e7 and Knight b6 and b6 rook to
use
yeah the position will be oops let's not
play the second move in the variation
then the first move in the variation the
position will be a bit more imbalanced a
pong could be weak dark squares can also
be weak but at least I'm completing
developments all night c5 could actually
be annoying yeah somehow I I think I
actually just mishandled it I was
feeling good after it b5 just forgot
about a4 yeah so I could play d6 maybe
it still ideas 95 of course take in d5
also interesting d5 apply pressure mine
use of rook to e8 I think I'll play d5
there's some line where like takes takes
like c5 takes takes and white has two
bishops versus two nights I wrote d8 and
things are controlled whoa I've got a
pause hang really okay it's very messy
now the e4 is also attacked my bishops
attacked I probably have to take first
that's a problem because yeah if takes
takes that's not good
not a good position I'm gonna have to
take here okay I'm gonna be down a pawn
I'll still have some some compensation
maybe some initiative can take here is
e4 still I mean there's I have two
attackers it's just a matter of dealing
with the Queen side if Knight takes I
play this and I hit the b2 pawn rook
takes I mean the same thing basically
rook takes I have Queen 85 even in the
end so this might not actually not be so
bad
Queen b7 like we miss having like c5
Queen takes B - looks okay
I mean I maybe I was just under
estimating White's position earlier
it actually looks very reasonable now
because there's basically three things
which are all attacked now I can take on
B to some weird lines with E 5 I don't
think they work maybe they do work
oh no e five my queen can always come
back alright so let's take upon hitting
the rook kind of pawn still attacks
thing for white is okay Brooke b1 now
Queen C three ideas now that then rook
b3 hmmm Queen C 3 or a p3 Queen C 4 who
actually finds a nice home on c4 alright
it can't easily be attacked by really
anything I'll put more pressure on e4 I
mean these pieces are a bit fragile the
pond is still delicate lots of things in
whites position are delicate and the
structure it actually favors black now
because this pond is just isolated this
is one happy pawn Island Queen d3 is a
move Queen d3 maybe 95 take sticks and
then Bishop and e4 are still attacked
what else to do
we're trading Queens we'll have some
some sort of positional endgame there's
some trick though if takes takes bishops
attacks kind of a [ __ ] back to there's
Knight d2 so it takes takes you might
doesn't have to move the bishop its
defended might see Bishop g5 yeah it's
annoying move the ideas of rook c8 I
think this is actually okay rook c8
because if takes takes and White has two
problems a nice attacked and I'm also
finding Knight d2 someone else knows why
I do here if 93 I can take I attack this
probably run upon so we might see rook
b5 Rick b5 looks very wrong though it'd
be fine maybe you're okay to eventually
over could be five maybe Knights nine
eight three even now 93 is a nice smooth
simple removal of the guard so I think
White's in trouble here because there's
lots of things to be worried about the
Knights the pawn the D 2 square so
Knight e3 so can I take some funny line
like takes takes takes takes in the 92
in the end
otherwise I'm just winning upon and if
takes back then I Knight takes I tack
the bishop in 92 is almost guaranteed
link takes takes if work takes I just
win a piece of pawn takes I Fork and
then I'll be up like an exchange at
least very time is looking well my moves
should have expected that
I mean okay I'll be up a pawn I win more
and there's a few Canada moves here
there's 95 there's III 93 is probably
bad I mean there's taking over then rook
F takes well this is really interesting
takes if either rook takes I've 94 again
with 92 and hitting g5 could be very
nice the thing is if takes takes then
maybe I take here more trades now let's
start with this okay this so this is
what I was hoping kind of for assuming
it works 94 i Lou I leave f7 undefended
by hit the bishop I mean if the bishop
moves where it was defended with h4 than
92 I think I'm winning material as I
stopped rook g3 in the process
yeah this is like I'm forking a bishop
and another fork and there might be some
tricks but I'm not seeing anything for
whites what it looked like to
counter-attack somehow but okay there's
no rock out for my Knights defended whoa
so I just take the bishop not sure if
that was intentional or just a blunder
you either way I'm just up a knight hey
pawns are equal still of fights I mean
this looks good and each [ __ ] might be
coming so I'm looking at 93 where does
the rook move
maybe f4 and takes takes chicks let's do
this
and this is a time black should probably
play aggressively because I have an
extra night more attacking potential I'm
envisioning we might get some position
where I think these pawns get traded and
I'll have to convert I cook in Knights
versus rook white takes takes takes h4
I've known a seven if necessary okay
yeah I'm happy to simplify in these
types of positions you should trade
pawns and not or you should trade pieces
and not pawns
okay so 907 there's also this move and
both are probably winning this man of
seven safety expecting yeah now White's
threatening maiden to h5s a move not h6
is a move each five each one's not weak
and now I have a thread of this I'm also
securing the G for square which will be
very nice for the night that's actually
a very annoying move defending and
attacking but there's no immediate
threat I just have to move quicker
though I mean maybe I can play King King
here seven Roach III start with this
I'll play like rook a7 preventing rookie
seven and now I just want to maneuver in
the Knight to g5 or g4 and maybe create
some mating attack that time is like the
biggest issue here and I can like cocoon
like g6 roachie seven if necessary and
also still ideas of just second rank
domination um is this winning
immediately oh it's so close to winning
I think it's winning immediately
actually a rook here if the King moves
here here there's a fork and fork f1 I
have this move and White's bound to get
forked or lose a rook there's no work
here because I just take alright that
was nice good to stay focused I was kind
of nervous out of the opening like my
position looked a little bit shaky but I
was not looking at all at the chat so
yes it really didn't make a difference
if people were suggesting moves or not
okay good to see there's some mods here
okay win streak so alive was that 60 65
games right 65 years yeah I was actually
surprised she didn't really know the
opening because anyone who studies this
at least those white I mean you should
know the the mainline 94 f3 is kind of
an amateur type move but maybe it's
playable but we can see like masters
database doesn't entirely approve um and
like b3 ah d5 immediately do you find
immediately kind can why take
Oh work th fancy very fancy
yeah b5 was probably the wrong just bad
timing so I think a 4 is like actually
really strong and white might actually
just be better here like okay we
couldn't check stock fish stock fish
okay maybe doesn't entirely know do I
play the best line it takes takes in d5
yeah Oh Bishop d6 I didn't even consider
that's such a weird move I know it's
playable in other types of additions g5
right no oh I played Bishop e7 and this
was probably just bad cuz I just forgot
like the white can get the bishop here
then things got messy and of course
stock fish like would crush here
probably like c3
and yeah white just wants a position
where like things open up and white
grabs the bishop hair and a6 is still
weak all right um anything else to talk
about I mean after the position kind of
what happened the position and like
after Queen digs b2 I was feeling very
good and then the conversion was
relatively smooth actually the tactical
ideas were nice I think starting with
you've been starting with this sequence
like 95 every move I have a threats like
takes takes just wanting to take the
bishop threaten to in the pawn I keep
initiative and then yeah so I won the
pawn here and then this move I was and I
was happy to find this even before
taking because it also works here like
hitting this in this and knights are
tricky this is just winning for black I
assume yeah okay
I'll probably put that on YouTube I am
versus I am sir Jake kill Clemente Oh
interesting
yeah for the YouTube audience thanks for
watching the twitch audience do I play
one more game